on august 10th the senate approved the
infrastructure investment and jobs act a
bipartisan package investing in roads
bridges broadband water power irs
cryptocurrency reporting and other
provisions the senate has proposed the
bill will be partially paid for with
unused coveted funds but the misnomer in
this statement is that businesses in
need were counting on these funds in
order to survive the pandemic on top of
that the government would be withdrawing
these funds for businesses at a time
when the delta variant is rising and the
near future is uncertain when the
american rescue plan act of 2021 was
passed in march the employee retention
credit was originally expanded for wages
paid through december 31st 2021 but the
new infrastructure bill plans to end the
employee retention credit early and not
allow businesses to claim up to a 7 000
per employee credit for the fourth
quarter of 2021 this would ultimately
redirect about 51 billion dollars in
fourth quarter funds from employee
retention to the infrastructure plan
with many state and local shutdown
orders lifted most employers will only
be able to avail themselves of credit if
they can reflect a significant decline
in gross receipts
basically this means that employers must
establish that their business still
hasn't recovered to their pre-pandemic
revenue streams to qualify a business
must show a greater than 20 gross
receipts decline in a 2021 quarter when
compared to the same quarter in 2019 and
more businesses are reporting difficulty
in hiring workers as many of them are
hesitant to return for a number of
reasons including unemployment benefits
and a fear of the delta variant if no
changes are made and the employer
retention credit plan continues as is it
may be up to small businesses themselves
to figure out how to make up for the
shortfall or if they can even keep their
doors open
you